know in many parts of Latin America
today is Mother's Day yeah officially
Mother's Day it is time to celebrate mom
but also encourage good health Lorna
Grady joining us live at CSN in North
Las Vegas to talk about how to keep our
moms healthy and waking them up with
some beautiful mariachi music
yes oh good morning you guys yes and
good morning and Felicia De Las Madres
to everyone out there all the mamas out
there and my mama included we got here
Debbie Carrillo with csn's Mariachi
Plata Debbie quickly tell me here why
did you want to sing Mariachi why is
that important for you
it all started because my dad he was my
inspiration so it really started at a
young age for me so yeah I think my dad
for that a lot and how's Mama feel about
it she's very supportive without further
Ado like I'll let you guys take the
reins here singing Las Mananitas here
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
yeah
all right we're gonna have more music
later on this morning too so don't go
anywhere again here at CSN in North Las
Vegas I'll say my name is
now back to you guys